whenever we talk about roe v wade or
abortion it like turns into this major
long conversation and so i was like if
we open with this it's going to be an
hour of debating abortion
so i don't know maybe we should have
it's the bigger news here but um ladies
and gentlemen
from cnbc supreme court conservatives
look ready to gut roe v wade during
arguments in mississippi abortion case
it was today mississippi wants to ban
abortions after 15 weeks and the supreme
court heard oral arguments and boy did
the left have almost no argument ah look
you guys know me i'm pro-choice i am not
pro-abortion the modern left in my
opinion is pro-abortion not pro-choice
and pro-choice is few and far between if
exists at all
i think the pro-choice individuals have
more in common with pro-lifers but they
do disagree
i heard some of the arguments you could
listen to it
uh
chief jesus roberts made excellent
points and he did compare the u.s to
other countries and he still made good
points
the left seemingly had no real argument
and it got to the point where a reporter
from slate tweeted the argue the
arguments are in the supreme court will
overturn roe v wade in june 2022.
he then deleted the tweet and said too
many people thought it was a statement
of fact he's like what i'm saying is
it's a prediction these are leftist
reporters the nbc news tweeted it
appears the conservatives are going to
repeal something i'm paraphrasing repeal
or strike down roe v wade there are 12
states with what's called trigger laws
which means as soon as roe v wade is
overturned they instantly go into effect
they've already been passed and abortion
will be immediately banned
it is believed that many more states
will then ban abortion and you will have
blue states that allow it red states
that don't
the supreme i'm trying to say it again
we don't know it's going to happen it
might not
but based on what these the justices
were arguing
kavanaugh man
he hid it out of the park and i have to
agree with him he said you have like he
based i'll paraphrase he was like you
haven't presented an argument as to why
this is a an issue for the supreme court
this sounds like something
congress needs to address
and i'm like he's right
the supreme court shouldn't be deciding
whether something is banned or not
banned
congress needs to pass laws legislating
this stuff on that alone
and also listening to the argument from
the um solicitor general who is like
defending um roe v wade
she was just saying like the right to
abortion is in the 14th amendment and
and and i think it was um
clarence thomas was like
what
i can read the second amendment that
says something
i i can't i don't know where what you're
getting at with that so so yeah this uh
this seems like the end i know luke luke
was celebrating earlier i don't know
about that i i saw some weird videos on
twitter today of of women taking uh i
think it was abortion pills claiming to
yeah claiming to or doing it i don't
know but
it it's such a complicated debate
there's so much emotion involved in this
it's and and i don't think people
celebrating abortions is is something
that is tasteful to say the least it's
something that was very concerning to
see and you know there's there's
different uh aspects there's different
places where you could be on the
spectrum here where there's and there's
of course people arguing that if you do
take an abortion you are killing a life
and therefore you are trampling on
somebody else's life so that's where the
argument gets complicated all right luke
garlic so what's what's your position uh
i need i i honestly want to do more
research into this i don't want to make
uh a conclusion because it's a question
that's very difficult to answer and not
having done enough research on it i
don't feel well versed to expose any
opinions on it so be completely honest
with you so what you're saying is that
you're sitting back as babies are being
murdered and you're okay with that
there's a nice fence that i see here
it's nice to sit on some fences
sometimes i don't there's nothing
but being honest here
you know
there's things that i believe personally
and there's things i believe the
government should be involved in um i
don't think the government should be
involved in in anything but people are
arguing that when you're committing an
abortion you are killing another
individual and that argument is
compelling to a lot of people and i i
think it should be an argument that
should be talked about more
well i think cut off time is important
like after how many weeks and i remain
hesitantly pro-choice on this issue i i
don't really publicly share my opinions
on this like luke here um
but but i think i think it's what is it
12 weeks for when the baby has a
heartbeat i believe
that seems to be potentially a logical
cutoff like after 12 weeks then
potentially maybe we shouldn't be able
to or maybe a bit after that i don't
know but it's it's a matter of having a
reasonable cutoff point
i know luke's trying to uh be careful
here but the reason is is you know
before the show he actually confirmed to
me he's pro-death
actually pro-life at all
he's like send them all to the camps
uh there's no there's no there's no
fence on this issue it's one of the
hardest issues it is ethically yeah but
i was i was you know reading a lot about
roe v wade and um the initial rulings
basically the idea is
uh man
insanely complicated
you can't uh what they're saying is
they don't want you to be able to abort
after the fetus is viable because at
that point you're dealing with a
self-sustaining independent life
before that the baby is not able to live
outside so so um how many weeks are we
talking 24 20 24 uh on and i guess
initially during the initial argument in
roe v wade it was like 26 and beyond was
viable and now with medical technology
it's gone on 24. and so
you know pro lifers are basically like
don't abort for any reason
and what's happening now in mississippi
is they're saying after 15 weeks you
can't get an abortion john roberts
was talking to
um her name um
what's her name i can't remember her
name the solicitor general and he was
like if you're talking about the issue
of choice
i don't understand how 15 weeks is not
adequate time to make a choice and she
did not have an argument and he brought
up european countries he said in many
european countries they have you know
less time than we do and then she lied
and said no they they uh allow abortion
up to the point of um
uh viability that's not true and it's
not true at all yeah europe is actually
very strict i think 12 weeks much more
so than yeah why have they chosen 15 by
the way here what's what's the rationale
behind 15 that's the heartbeat right
yeah i think so 15 is around the time
1560's around the time of heartbeat i
thought it was 12 for heartbeat but
maybe maybe you're right i think it's
also important for people to distinguish
what they believe personally and what
would they rather have the government do
personally i'm not a fan of government
uh but personally if i had a situation
where
you know i was potentially having a
child i would do everything in my power
to have that child and i would do
everything to make sure that there
wasn't an abortion um
personally speaking from my own personal
perspective so that's what i would do
there's an interesting argument in this
whole debate that basically came up and
it's if a woman is pregnant with a baby
and the baby is not able to sustain
itself
then
i don't think it's it's the state's
right to determine that someone has to
share their body with someone else
but the issue for me is if someone has
to if a woman has to go to a doctor and
the doctor says something like
look you've got this you know problem
it's a serious health issue and it could
kill both of you and we're worried about
this understanding the argument as i've
talked to sheamus from freedom tom's a
lot about this a lot he's like doctors
can be wrong about that and often we'll
we'll pressure towards abortion but um
that argument aside if this woman has
has an uh a serious medical issue it's
traumatizing it's serious i don't like
the idea that she goes to the government
and seeks out approval or paperwork
however
if we're at a certain point where on
average the baby is viable you are now
asking to terminate a sustainable life
form you you are now saying to the
government i would like to kill this
this life okay at that point i think
it's even absurd that you can go to the
government request termination of
someone else
if the baby can live outside the womb
then i don't understand why we don't
just say okay well we're gonna take the
baby out of the room and let it live
well what's what is life i mean just lay
there in a in a cradle until it starves
to death or are we having someone take
no there they put it in the premature
baby incubation someone's got to feed it
and like take care of it someone's got
to start mothering it immediately when
it's removed from the water these are
tough moral questions ian what's the
alternative we say we have this baby we
have a let's say you have a nine month a
full-term baby fresh out of out of the
the womb and then and then you're like
well who's going to feed it yeah i won't
so what do you do well there's also
there's also a lot of people who can't
have children and wish they can have
children and they wish they could adopt
but our adopting adoption system is
absolutely crazy to the point where many
americans are literally going to china
and russia in order to get babies there
because the process is so much easier
and simpler to do it over there than to
jump through all the government hoops
here in the united states that actively
intervenes and and you know some would
argue prevents people from being able to
adopt children here in the united states
so there's also arguments for that as
well um
and again this is a very difficult
discussion a lot of emotion here um you
know life
you know how how does it begin i mean
that's a conception that's end of story
life is pretty
precious in my opinion it should be
preserved at
at all costs i'm not i'm this is a very
sensitive issue and we already got a
super chat where they're like long story
short tim's hypocritical
hypocritical for opposing the death
penalty but first for being pro-choice i
am pro-abortion i think killing is wrong
i think using abortion as contraception
is disgusting the problem is
saying to the government you have a
right to to be in the doctor's room with
pers with a person to demand their
papers i don't think it should be effect
allowed for for for vaccines i don't
think it should be allowed for when you
have to go to a doctor you say yo my
life sucks i have a serious problem and
i and i think about the challenge here
in that there are a lot of women who are
crying saying please please save my baby
and after saying ma'am i can't it's
ectopic it's not gonna work and then
he's like now in order to save you fill
out this government form and go talk to
your local politician about why this is
what you need to do i don't like the
idea of the government being involved in
that i certainly despise to a great
degree that people abuse the system to
be like
accidentally got pregnant instead of
using birth control i'll just kill it
that's screwed up that's bad and wrong
and then i sit there like with my head
shaking like how do you reconcile this i
cannot
entertain the idea of the government
being given authority over our bodies
and having a right to be in these
medical rooms there is an interesting
argument though about the the time
duration this is a there's no middle
ground here this is the challenge here
i think killing is wrong i think there
are certain circumstances where you have
to it's unfortunate kyle rittenhouse
shouldn't have had to kill the people he
did but he was defending himself and i
don't think he should go to prison for
it and i wish those people didn't lose
their lives no matter how awful they are
sometimes you have no choice if there is
a woman who has a serious medical issue
a legitimate one i'm not talking about
stupid lies or arguments or whatever i'm
talking about legitimate like yo the
heart is busted up and it's not going to
survive and it might kill you too and
the mother is crying begging for help
saying please don't let this be true and
now she's got to go to the government
for approval man screw that i'm not all
about that i i think that's ridiculous
that kyle rittenhouse had to justify to
a court with a threat of life in prison
because he was simply trying to save his
own life and i view the the pre the
issue is very similarly when it comes to
legitimate arguments from women who are
dealing with this stuff it is very very
difficult to reconcile i can fully admit
hands down michelle wolf and lena dunham
these people sicken me when they're
celebrating this stuff and cheering for
it and women are standing outside of
courtrooms taking pills mocking it but
the problem is you know i'll tell you
this this is another problem it's really
simple
a pro-choice position is is ridiculously
close to the pro-lifers they're both
saying man we really hate this and the
pro-lifers are like well we don't want
there to be any excuse for why they're
going to get away with doing this and
many of the pro-choicers the legitimate
ones are like man but getting the
government involved and then you have
the pro-abortion people which is the
modern mainstream left and they're
celebrating this trash so look
i don't want the death penalty i don't
want abortions i recognize sometimes
people die i recognize sometimes they're
abortions i don't have all the answers
morally but i just don't like the
government getting involved in people's
business
yeah i think also to add to your point i
think you're absolutely right and it's
important to look at costs and benefits
for when implementing a policy you can't
just look at the benefits and the costs
or sorry just the benefits or the costs
like when it came to covid people are
all about lockdowns lockdowns but and
obviously they save lives that's true
when it comes to covid but when it comes
to the economy then it's totally
different calculation so in this case
you know allowing you know being
pro-choice doesn't mean that you're
pro-abortion it's just that you think
that uh government mandates and
government power in this case is more
dangerous than certain people abusing
that choice so you're looking at the
cost and deeming that to be more
dangerous than the benefit there's an
interesting potential argument here as
well what if there was no government
involvement in any abortion but the
doctor did have to have a legitimate
reason how about that that's a good idea
well you know there's there's different
spectrums here and i think one of the
worst runs was what happened when a lot
of very powerful eugenicists in the
united states implemented a one-child
policy in the united states and had a
situation where the government there was
forcing people to have abortions because
they didn't want them to have more than
one child so that's the the inverse of a
situation where the government got
involved in abortions but made it
mandatory for almost everyone to take it
if they wanted to have a second child
there's also a lot of very dark history
when it comes to margaret sanger plant
planned parenthood how it started a lot
of letters by margaret sanger that are
absolutely troubling that are absolutely
worrying and when you really delve into
a lot of
government intervening in this specific
realm i think it highlights a very
sinister dark past that is worth
conversing and understanding before kind
of jumping into uh this position because
i think it does play into the
government's role here these are this
this is such an impossible it is a moral
conundrum
i mean let's let's imagine a rape victim
someone who was not irresponsible
someone who did not make that choice who
is now being told by the government you
are you are obligated to share your body
and blood your bodily autonomy is hereby
revoked you are now you know to to
provide for this other like the girl
wants to kill the baby she's going to
kill the baby whether the government
tells her it's legal or not we've had
i've heard anecdotal stories of people
going to like back alleys to get these
black dark abortions under the table
illegally and like she gets hurt during
the
thing because it's not done on the on
the up and up she takes some sort of
injury like
you're not gonna stop it it's been going
on since the dawn of humanity whether
we've been destroying babies that aren't
viable like they come out and they have
their crippled or something and they
they would kill the baby and then the
spartans man yeah they would just like
leave it in the woods right and see if
it survived to play devil's advocate on
that argument though like that um from
what i've read the the rape cases are
only about one percent cases for
abortions well right so
so some people say that you shouldn't
base policy based on the one percent of
cases i don't think rape is an excuse
for killing a baby for terminating the
life i think the problem though is
there's a lot of very serious
philosophical arguments about
responsibility and choice a lot of
people immediately go to how could you
be against the death penalty but for
abortion it's like there's completely
different
philosophical arguments there i i think
you're mansplaining too much tim what
about the guys who who get pregnant and
uh what is the what does the woman here
think about this debate linda oh boy
luke uh you uh you triggered a firestorm
here because i've been sitting listening
and i've been thinking how wonderful it
is that i've been able to maintain my
silence as long as they have this is
like my hail to die on this is what i
really care about you're correct that a
vanishingly small number of abortions
are in fact committed because they are a
result of rape or incest i use numbers
from the gupmaker institute which is
what uh planned parenthood uses for
their numbers so they err on the side of
maybe trying to pump those numbers up to
kind of support
the idea that abortion is actually
medically necessary and i agree with tim
because i know people who are the result
of rape and they are wonderful people
they were adopted by people who care
very much about them and of course they
would much rather be alive
than be dead and and that's why i said
right i think the conservatives who
argue the rape or incest exception i
don't understand that at all yeah i
don't see how it's the baby's fault that
they were conceived through it however
there's there's an issue of someone
being forced to share their body with
someone else so if the government came
to me right now and said we're gonna
hook up your blood to ian because ian
needs your blood to live i'd be like
hell no right and they'd be like well
you should have been more responsible i
didn't choose that right so that's the
the personal autonomy problem further
the problem arises that yeah one percent
is you know but and so i think it's 99
isn't it like 99 of abortions are no
reason given elective yeah either no
reason given i think i think i think
it's i think abortion is contraception
is wrong but i don't know how you deal
with it then when someone can walk in
there and be like rape
yeah and then what do you do to the
actual rape victims who are like you
can't force me to share my body with
somebody else i didn't choose this
i don't have the answers man
i think i think one of the most
compelling arguments on the pro-life
side is what luke was alluding to
earlier um and i've looked at the data
on this that there is actually higher
need for adoption than there is actual
supply for when it comes to very young
children i believe that changes for for
kids after the age of like six like
there's an abundance of kids in foster
care homes who aren't able to find
parents to adopt them but when it comes
to really young infants from what i
understand there's a huge huge
need but it's not met with with the same
level of supply so arguably you could
say that we should
um you know have pro-life policy and let
people give birth to kids and give it
off to adoption because there are so
many parents gay couples also who are
looking to adopt and it's very very hard
because there's a very very low supply i
do think that uh one of the things that
we could do to help solve the problem of
abortion is to reform the adoption
system
make it simpler
so
one of the problems with roe v wade is
that it never should have been
legislated at the federal level because
what they found was that abortion was
becoming more socially acceptable before
they passed roby wade if they had gone
state to state and said do you guys want
abortion and each individual state had
used their 10th amendment rights to say
we do want it we don't want it because
this is not in fact a duty left to the
federal government by the constitution
thereby meaning it should be left to the
state there are no emanations and
numbers in the 14th amendment that say
that a woman should be allowed to remove
her child's body from her body by force
necessary so i think that um
we are you're correct that it is very
nuanced and i hate to see leftists being
so insane but i thank them for making my
case for me because no one can look at
these women standing on the steps of
this building taking these abortion
pills and just shouting their abortion
it's phil phillipanti
from all that remains tweeted that if
there's one issue that's going to push
moderates to the conservatives it's the
issue of abortion because the leftist
argument on all this stuff is like
i mean it's evil
it is it is absolutely it is amoral it
is unethical it is it is evil they don't
treat life with value and look i get it
when they talk about moral relativism oh
yeah i think it's a real thing and i
think when you have a bunch of people
who lack a moral framework they have no
problem
literally killing burning down buildings
and celebrating it and we've seen that
with the riots all throughout last year
25 directly dead as a result of the
george floyd riots and not an ounce of
remorse in fact they still celebrate it
when uh when um
was it aaron danielson that was his name
the guy in portland who took to the
chest yeah they cheered for it yeah when
uh what happened after charlottesville
everyone on the right
mourned and said this is terrible we're
we're shocked by this it's because you
look at the moral foundations of these
people and they don't have any we talk
about you know care and fairness now
whatever the moderate modern leftists
are they are just a chaotic destructive
force they have no principles there is
no logic i'm not talking about literally
everyone on the left i'm talking about
the weird cultist woke whatever cheering
for death taking abortion pills
celebrating the stuff that's just amoral
outright and to me overtly evil my issue
is just like wow i'm trying to be good
i'm trying to respect everybody but boy
is it hard when you have a woman who is
an autonomous lifeform with rights and a
baby who's an autonomous lifeform with
rights and how do we reconcile that with
what the government gets to do ben
shapiro
brilliant argument that if there's one
thing the state does do it's protect
life in which case when it comes to the
issue of a child a baby which and life
does begin a conception any any other
argument otherwise is a ridiculous
political argument uh then the
government should be involved in whether
or not life is terminated and i want to
address that one very very seriously
because
there look
when when the sperm and the head come
together you get unique dna and from
that point on there is a unique set of
dna that is new life the new life is now
created when we had vosh on the show he
was talking with charlie kirk and he was
asked when does he think life life
starts he's like uh birth and i'm like
so if the baby is not born from the
woman it's like not alive but you can
you can have a baby at eight months be
removed by a c-section and it's and it's
alive and self-sustaining
why is birth the point what is traveling
through the vagina and the vulva have to
do with whether or not this baby is
literally living i've heard from people
that say three months three months is
when life starts because babies can't
remember anything before that and i'm
like
so people who have you know serious
amnesia issues or short-term memory
issues and can't remember things aren't
alive it's a ridiculous argument life
begins at conception that's it's just
it's it's it's a political argument to
say otherwise moving on from there you
have a very serious conundrum of who
gets to decide when a life is is is
terminated i don't like the death
penalty and i don't like abortion but i
recognize death and you get a couple of
skin cells in a in a petri dish it's
alive it's not a human
i think that's when does it become a
human is the is the debate
i think if is the skin going to uh grow
and become unknown
well the answer is no ian you don't know
it's still no we do what do you mean
about science when does the baby in
utero become a human like at what point
do we say it's it's a lie from
conception i agree living muscle tissue
but at what point do we acknowledge
human is it heartbeat is it a brain
three weeks i think nine weeks 12 weeks
well it's not really human at that point
yet though so this is such an
interesting argument because
if you watched a dog
sperm meet a dog
egg
would you ask the question
is that a dog would there were there any
doubt in your mind that a little puppy
would result from that union
probably not i don't understand why we
do this with humans
it's it's it's
the reason i disagree with you is that
it would be like looking at a child and
being like it's not it's not a human
because
i mean we don't know that it'll become a
mature adult who can reproduce no it's a
zygote if you look at a zygote you're
arguing a different stage of human life
doesn't mean well you don't you don't
know what it's going to become yet when
you're looking at a zygote you don't
unless you know that it was a human
sperm an egg or a sperm and egg you
don't know what it's going to turn into
so i think in ian's defense i think the
differentiation you're trying to make
potentially is in terms of like pain
perception potentially you could say
like for like at what stage does the
does the
you know fetus like feel pain and it's
actually different i mean arguably then
that argument is like terry shivoh
remember that whole thing
a person in a vegetative state isn't
alive
oh what if someone's in a coma they
can't respond to stimuli you're just
like me they're dead
we have no idea if they'll come too and
then a week later they wake up
but sperm and egg versus an actual fetus
that has a heartbeat like in terms of
feeling pain after you terminate that
would be different i'm saying i don't
think pain is relevant to the
conversation of whether someone has
rights there are people who literally
can't feel i'm saying arguably in terms
of suffering if we're measuring based on
suffering but i don't think we are
okay like if if if an old man is
comatose you know guy in his 60s is
comatose he has he has rights
and
i think there's an interesting question
about do we have
are we obligated to give him life
support and the answer that is probably
no but we can and maybe it's the right
thing to do i don't think healthcare is
a human right if there's someone lying
on the ground in the woods in their
comatose you can be like they will die
like without
assistance from someone else they have
no right to it but we do want to save
them when it comes to uh
like so my point is that pain is not
relevant to whether or not we want
someone to live or they have the right
to live or anything like that just
because someone can feel pain or can
suffer doesn't mean we let them die we
usually choose to preserve life but
obviously there is a difference morally
speaking there is some difference there
i
don't agree in terms of how much harm
you're inflicting on just a
an egg in a sperm versus an actual fetus
you know 20 weeks in eggness you know
obviously there's a difference i'm not
i'm not saying that that that's a big
they're different but it is fair it is
fair to say that we treat we we do as a
culture treat uh
fertilized eggs very very differently
than we would like an actual baby if a
woman you know has a fertilized egg and
then miscarries and doesn't know what
happened and just you know it just
flushed out the body no there's no
murder trial there's no murder
investigation if she gives birth to a
baby and then something happens and the
baby dies in the crib the cops are going
to come and try and figure out what
happened so there's a certain point
where the government would intervene and
wouldn't intervene that being said
i'm not i think the government is doing
a heck of a bad job and that's why i
don't like them i don't like the
government and system in a lot of ways
and a lot of things they do so one of
the things that i was going to add to
luke's point from earlier was that i
feel like a lot of this would be
resolved if we reduce the size of the
government and reduce their overreach if
we kind of scale back the involvement
that they have in the adoption process
if we scaled it all the way back from
telling what the woman what they can and
can't do if we left it to doctors if we
left it to mothers um but i at the end
of the day i have to say that i
genuinely feel that um this is a
cultural problem and i need to fix the
culture figured it out what you got you
got to pull trump a big ask right you
guys what the big ask is nice yeah so a
big ask you you know read art of the
deal right that's what that's trump's
book right and it's basically like you
know maybe i want to sell out no what's
good example i want to um
i want to buy
i want to hire you to do a job
and so what you do with the big ask is
you'll say okay i'll do this job you
what you really want is 50 bucks but you
know if you start with 50 i'm gonna
negotiate down so you say i want 500 and
then i go whoa whoa that's crazy and
then you go well 500 is my number and
then i say i can't i can't do that and
you go okay fine
what if we do three no no three still
nuts well now you're getting me down a
lot bro will we do 250
all right 250. the big ask is you ask
for way more than you want so you
negotiate down to where you really want
to be it's simple all we have to do is
have someone campaign on forced abortion
oh that way everyone freaks out
the china policy
ted turner liked that one uh so did uh
bill gates's dad who was connected to
planned parenthood again there's so much
things i can talk about interesting but
uh that's not a policy that that's too
absurd tim that's a policy that many
people have argued for they're doing it
right now in china and the uyghur camps
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you